hi teagan hi sarah hi
are you still on cloud nine from seeing
kelly clarkson
do a cover of closer on the kelly
clarkson show
[Music]
my understanding was that she had this
karaoke show
and that someone was going to go on the
show and sing the song that's that's
what i understood
so the other morning when i woke up and
our whole feed was kelly clarkson kelly
clarkson i like clicked on it
and saw her absolute badass smash
of our song closer and i i just couldn't
i had i went back and looked at the
email i'm like how did i get this so
wrong what a fun song i love that song
so much there are very few songs that
can keep me on a treadmill people
that's one of them it was so cool it was
so exciting there's literally no better
compliment than to see someone who
can actually sing who's unbelievably
talented just a world-class artist like
that to sing one of our songs it was
just a total thrill it was a wonderful
wonderful wonderful way to make i just
lived off of that for like two days it
was wonderful
it was great and sarah you know i
thought once i saw that
cover i was like whoa um you both
could do an epic kelly clarkson cover
and put it out
because you would kill since you've been
gone just saying
what's so tough though i and i'm not i
say this
with the most respect i can i can muster
for ourselves
we are not great enough singers i don't
think we can do it
i just you know when you see one of
those ladies out
jogging around the schoolyard and she's
got weights and you're like oh she's
just starting like a new
workout regimen and then you see like an
olympic athlete
you decide in that scenario you tell me
who you think i'm referring to with that
like obviously kelly clarkson is not the
lady with the weights running around
my school is now available on paperback
i could not put this
down you did not really hold back in
this book and that is something that i
appreciated we definitely pledged
to tell as true to the story as we
possibly could
you know give the version that that we
feel would
best depict what honestly happened you
know for us it was
we sold it as the origin story of our
band and of us and
coming out and coming of age and all of
that and so it was important to tell
that story
the best that we could
it is national coming out day this
weekend what would you say
to anyone who is struggling with coming
out
for me it's been 22 years since i came
out and
you know the way that i present myself
as a as an
out queer person it's it's it's almost
like it's always evolving
you know the significant wisdom that
i've that i've
uh that i've acquired over these last 22
years is that
it is just different for everyone i
think for a lot of people
living in the closet or having secret
lives or whatever that can be very
damaging
to you and the people around you and you
know i think getting right with yourself
um accepting yourself is um is probably
the most important coming out you're
ever gonna have
you know in looking back at writing our
book high school one of the things that
really struck me
about writing about my young version you
know the young version of me was just
how in denial and and self-loathing i
was even
even as i was having experiences with
women
i uh i realized that i was really unable
to accept who i was
and that was painful for me and it in
i think adulthood i eventually came to
the realization that
i can't really expect anyone to treat me
with respect or
love or care for me if i'm not treating
myself with love and
care and um and i think that finding
that sort of acceptance for myself has
allowed me to sort of be
a healthier and happier person while i
was reading this
uh memoir i thought in my mind this
would be
such an incredible queer coming of age
series um is that something that either
of you have ever
thought about or would you want to make
a series based on your own lives
yes we would tegan and i are story
tellers that's what we are whether we're
using the medium of music
or we're using our voices through you
know books um
we really want to see our story told and
we love the idea of collaboration with
other
types of creative folks so the idea that
we might be able to
to get this out in another way is
exciting and just a challenge like how
do we find
teenage twins who you know who can who
can capture this
we have a wonderful creative
collaborative partner who's working with
us on the pilot and
who's helping us develop the show and we
have found a home
uh for the time being uh to help us
develop the show and hopefully
i mean many steps ahead of us but
hopefully we will
be able to turn this into a tv show that
people will be able to see in the next
couple of years
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos